sonst sieht man dann so aus wie dieses
fette schweine entschuldigung sie müssen
schlaf zeit
[Musik]
was ist da der unterschied zwischen
zucker und crack fragen sich manche
leute ganz einfach track schreibt man
mit c
[Musik]
das ist wunderbar
hallo das ist fragen wie viel vor so
einer messe muss man den aufhören
süßigkeiten zu essen am besten anfänger
drei wochen davor an
sonst sieht man dann so aus wie dieses
fette schweine entschuldigung sie müssen
schaffen
wassersuppe schwarzer zucker ist das
gesünder oder weniger gesucht auf jeden
fall gesünder
können sie das noch mal sagen und dann
so die kamera zwingen kann auf jeden
fall gesünder
also so ganz können sie machen sie mit
beiden augen schwarz und weiß auf jeden
fall gesehen und dann mit beiden augen
zwingen kann ist auf jeden fall cool das
ist auf jeden fall gesünder
[Musik]
manchmal trügt der schein und selbst
leute die zu schwer wirken sind
eigentlich gar nicht übergewichtig es
sind eigentlich sehr sehr schlanke
personen gefangen den körper von sehr
dickem das nennt man auch transfette
hollywood ist doppelt wenn sie das auch
zum beispiel ein kind aus syrien sagen
na klar
und weil sie soll das dann reagieren zu
können
man braucht auch zucker ein etwas
unkonventioneller schokobrunnen
inspiriert an den ehemaligen toiletten
des antiken roms
[Musik]
ja das ist also der erste coupé der
jetzt in den markt kommt mit koran und
das ist natürlicher koffein das heißt
wenn sie zwei von diesem wunderschönen
cookie essen dann haben sie so viel wie
werden sie eine dose energy drink
trinken aber das nehme ich dann ganz
normal oral ein und nicht irgendwie so
zerbröseln und mit der nase das leben
wie so ein wie sie normalerweise ihre
nahrung aufnehmen ich weiß nicht wie sie
das sonst machen aber wenn sie so machen
sonst machen sie genau den richtigen weg
sie sind unglaublich hässlich was ist
denn sie sind denn ohne dieses kostüm
aus können sie auch so was praktisches
wie zum beispiel eine insulinspritze
modellieren insulinspritze etwas
spezielles wir machen das aber zum glück
des diabetes ist nicht das einzige was
man hier mitnehmen kann und damit zurück
ins studio über meinen arsch geigensolo
war doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]